>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Gail Shirazi: Hello.
I'm Gail Shirazi of the
Israel-Judaica Section here
at the Library of Congress.
Welcome to today's program.
"Babel Through the Latin
American Jewish Eyes," sponsored
by the Hebrew Language
[inaudible] and cosponsored
by the Hispanic Division here at the
Library of Congress in cooperation
with the Argentine Embassy.
If you haven't already
been to the LC website,
it's a treasure trove
of information.
Both the Hebraic section
and the Hispanic division have
wonderful websites describing their
collections and activities.
You can check it out at www.loc.gov.
Two announcements before we begin.
Please turn off your cell
phones and I have to announce
that we're being webcast.
So during the Q&A, it will be,
the audience will be scanned.
So if you don't want
to be in the webcast,
you might want to maybe step out.
Okay, I would like to thank Maritza
Gueler and the Argentine Embassy
and to welcome Maritza and Mr.
Louis Levitt, the cultural attache
at the Embassy of Argentina
who is sitting right here,
Mr. Levitt and Maritza.
And I want to thank the Hispanic
Division, [inaudible] office,
Kalina Tabarovsky [phonetic] of
the IJ section and special thanks
to our trio of presenters.
It gives me great personal
and professional pleasure
to introduce our panel today.
Mirta Kupferminc, Mirta is an
internationally [applause] known
multidisciplinary artist
who thinks the frontiers
in art are an innovation
to be transgressed.
Interesting.
Graciela Tova Shvartzman, a
psychoanalyst and professor
of Jewish history, and my dear
friend, Dr. Saul Sosnowski, scholar,
university professor and
author, specializing in Spanish,
Latin American and Judaic studies.
All three from Argentina.
They will speak about text
and art brought together
in extraordinary ways,
crossing languages, art,
Judaism, and psychoanalysis.
There'll be a Q&A following
the presentation.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Saul Sosnowski: Good afternoon.
And it's always wonderful
to be with Gail
because she does the work for you.
I was supposed to introduce
Mirta and Tova.
She did and very briefly but
very accurately because both
of them are each of them in
their own way transgressors.
They're always looking for
the hidden side of things,
one through art, the other
one through psychoanalysis.
And somehow what we are going to be
hearing today is precisely that kind
of intersection between three
components, between Judaism,
between art, and psychoanalysis,
one through a practicing artist,
the other one through a practicing
artist who is also a psychoanalyst.
So we're going to be hearing and
seeing very, very different things.
And I don't want to take time
out from their presentations.
So we will start with Mirta and
after that we will go with Tova
and after that it will be up to you.
I may interrupt every so often,
which is something I
sometimes do or may not.
Let's see how it goes.
Mirta.
>> Mirta Kupferminc: Thank you.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Thanks to all of you.
Thank you to the Hebrew Language
table and the Hispanic division here
at Library of Congress
in cooperation
with Argentinean Embassy.
Thank you for inviting us to
be able to share this talk,
our thoughts, our work with you.
This theme about and
questions about babel is based
on my personal experience of being
born as daughter of immigrants.
My parents, my father from
Poland, my mother from Hungary,
both Auschwitz survivors,
arrived in Argentina.
And the language that I
heard at home was different
from the external language
spoken at school, with friends,
and this provoked in me a kind
of otherness in my daily life.
So babel [inaudible] in languages
is a kind of natural temple for me
because babel is where
languages and in Genesis
where languages were born
differences in languages were born
for people not to be
able to understand.
And that is why I have
a very big body of work.
I realized organizing this
talk that I am working
with babel already
for 25 years perhaps.
So I would like to
continue my speaking,
sharing some images and
about my art itself.
So thank you.
This is a very, very
big etching, printing.
I will mix a little
bit with techniques.
So this is a very, very huge one.
I will tell in meters, sorry,
so you will translate to inches.
This is almost two meters high.
It's very, very big.
So you know to make this an
etching is a very hard work composed
by many plates, metal plates.
And all people are different kind
of people because we are talking
of differences are walking
around this kind of fire babel.
And the text and language
and textures are something
that always worries me and this work
that is called [inaudible] belongs
to a new body of work that is
called the Body of the Word
that everything is handmade.
I work on the rubber,
cutting the rubber
and these are digital
photographs that I make
with a real matter
that I made on hand.
So everything that
goes out from the mouth
and in this case also
this image of a woman
that everything what she
says turns to reality.
You know, I was always worried
to join my multiple identities
as a woman, as an Argentinean,
as a Jew
and that is why I developed
really many works,
I think that mainly trying to
join this multiple these aspects.
I also made with Saul Sosnowski.
Perhaps some of you know about this
work, about Borges and Kabbalah
that also joins this
Argentinean identity together
with this Jewish knowledge.
And in this case also
I work a lot with Tova.
We are launching a project,
already launched three years ago
but we are working in something that
is called LABA-BA, LABA Buenos Aires
that is a group of artists.
We make an open call.
We choose ten artists
of multiple disciplines
to study together about
a selected theme.
This time, this year
it was the other
and the theme we study is the same
theme that LABA New York study.
So now we are coming from the first
trip that Argentinean fellows made
to New York to present the work
together with the New York fellows.
So it was a very big experience.
And really what we are trying
to do is to expand something
that we think is very,
very valuable to offer this
to our Argentinean audience, to our
country because we are convinced --
I will speak about myself.
Sorry. I am convinced that
this is something very rich --
Jewish culture is something
very rich that we have to offer
to all Argentinean community that
perhaps you know that is shaped
by many, many, many
different cultures.
So this is my main goal
when I choose these works.
"Misunderstanding" is
the title of this work.
It's the same rubber cut with text
with words and you know very well
that usually what we say
or sometimes what we say
or what we think we said is not
exactly what the other person heard
or understood.
Another babel is called
this one, this work,
everything is done
by real text letters.
This one is called "The
Origin of Xenophobia"
because somehow these differences
between languages are a
demonstration or a beginning
to all xenophobia or
difference that we perceive.
It's a big challenge, yes,
to immigrate in a country
but also the ones that are
already there to receive,
to be able to receive people
that are coming from other place.
So these migrations that nowadays
are so active in the world,
this puts all of us in a very
special intimate condition also.
Other version of the same thoughts.
And another one.
You see the Hebrew
letters on the back.
These are overloaded
over a post layers
of very, very big hand-cut foam.
This is really very white,
not only in the photo.
So it's the texture.
And another one, etching,
this is metal etching.
And this is the one that
Gail chose for the flier.
You see there the good and the bad
because of course every, these many,
many, many languages
have their own aspects,
good aspects also not only bad, of
course, the differences are not bad.
I think that the big challenge
is to enjoy the differences.
So here, you have about the image.
If I talk about the image, the good
and the bad and the way of working,
this is a very spontaneous
gesture of the work,
then everything in the middle.
And now very briefly
I want to invite you
as a very first presentation to
show what I will present in October
in Jerusalem for the
Jerusalem Biennale.
The title of the work is
"Traduttore-Traditore"
because every translation is somehow
a betrayal, betrayal, thank you.
Sorry for my English.
That's why I make images for you to
understand a little bit at least.
But as I am speaking about this,
it's okay about the
difference between languages.
So this work will be settled
in the Jerusalem Biennale.
It's a very big building all
made of hand-cut, you see,
this is all text saying,
telling the tale of babel
in 70 different languages
with characters
of 70 different languages.
This is a draft, of course.
This was not built yet.
When you put your head inside that
hole -- This is not the draft.
This was built.
When you put your head inside,
if you look down that way,
you can see this feeling of
endless, like an infinite.
Of course, it is a game
playing with mirrors.
So this is the draft
of the presentation.
From inside, [inaudible] hearing.
You know it was a greeting that
the astronauts left on the moon
with Apollo 11 that it is not in 70
but in 55 languages, they greeted.
They said hello.
The 70 languages are chosen because
it is said that the relationship is
with the, yes, one of the, yes, but
no, Shem, the son of Noah, his sons,
each one was the ancestor
of a nation.
That's why 70 languages are chosen.
But the greetings are only in 55.
But these are real
recording that exists
that this was left on the moon.
So this is an example of how all
the 70 chosen languages will be
displayed on the surrounding
walls of the tower.
You see here Aramaic.
These are only some examples.
So if you come now to Jerusalem
first October, see you in Jerusalem.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Saul Sosnowski: Thank you, Mirta.
If it's okay with you, we'll
wait for comments, questions,
et cetera until we hear from
Tova who will be talking
about the intersection of
Judaism, art, and psychoanalysis.
And then we will have more time
to perhaps engage both of them
in a dialogue or a trialogue
depending how you feel we can
proceed with the questions
and the comments.
Tova, yours.
>> Tova Shvartzman: Okay.
Sorry about my accent,
speaking about languages.
I have no images.
I have letters here.
So I will read it.
I want to join Mirta and Saul
in thanking the organizer
for the opportunity to
meet with you today.
I would like to share with you
some thoughts about intersection
of Judaism, art, in this
case both visual literature
and psychoanalysis.
Judaism is a culture that places a
particular [inaudible] on the text.
Literature also centers on the text.
And psychoanalysis also
focuses on another text,
in this case on the
[inaudible] words.
This means that all
three meet at the text.
I view today's as a culture based
on foundational text
beginning with the "Bible."
Those foundational text like in
other cultures are unique answers
to the major questions that
humanity ask themselves
and these questions
may be summarized
in the answers that are the myths.
Myths provide these answers.
Their structure, the
myth's structures,
like Levi-Strauss discovered,
is always the same.
It doesn't matter which
culture they come from.
Psychoanalysis is a practice.
Within this practice,
it's not a matter
of interpreting an existing
text nor to seek out its author
but to discover the
structure of a narrative.
Lacan stated that the artist's
perception anticipate future events.
Just think of Kafka who for
some other man's solitude
as well as the [inaudible].
Visual artists and writers
often take the myths to write
in them how these answers
are still affecting our days.
I want to share with you one of
these answers, the myths of babel,
as written by Borges and
through psychoanalysis.
We don't have a patient,
just the text.
As you may know, Buenos Aires is
known for having the highest number
of psychoanalysts in the world.
I don't know if we
can be proud of it.
Borges didn't like
psychoanalysis, you know.
He used to say that this is sort
of narrative, not a science.
Well I agree with him
and so did Lacan.
It's a sort of narrative.
But this narrative
that affects people
if only they assume
responsibility of their own words.
A few years ago I had the great
privilege, thanks to Gail,
where is Gail, hey, to
[inaudible] in this building, no,
in the main building, of
seeing one of the letters
from the Freud archives here
in the Library of Congress
where Karl Abraham told Freud,
Talmudic thought cannot
have suddenly left us.
What is that Talmudic mode of
thought to which Abraham refers?
It is interpretation.
It is the freedom to hear in
each word not only communication
but fundamentally an
instrument to exercise freedom.
It is the answer to
fundamental reason
which only consider one language.
Every man is different
and it is that difference
where the [inaudible]
humanities exist.
We always encounter
constant misunderstanding
and perhaps we speak
the same language
but interpretation comes
always from misunderstanding.
[inaudible] means the tower of Babel
relates this theme as do [inaudible]
with a narrative that in turn
present the problem and its cause.
And almost always the cause is man's
fault, [inaudible] responsibility
for what is not right in this world.
However, we will try to read the
myths differently as did Borges
in his fictional text and
as psychoanalysis does.
Genesis means of the Tower of Babel
has an even greater appeal today
in the era of communications
where there are more and more ways
and means to communicate
and there is more
and more loneliness
and misunderstanding.
Men, humans, were punished by the
God of the gods with the confusion
of tongues for having
been arrogant and wanting
to build a tower to reach heaven.
They spoke a universal
language up to that point.
Then, different language appeared.
Borges has taken, he used several
times this term for his stories,
two of them, "The Library
of Babel" and "The Lottery
of Babel" are inspired by the
biblical [inaudible] to talk
about what writing books,
letters, and human knowledge means.
Their stories are amazing
metaphors that state
that the universe is symbolic,
maybe the myth is right.
There was a lost language.
That forgotten language was a
perfect fusion of sounds and meaning
that all the people, all
humanity goes through.
This language -- If that
language continued to exist,
it would not have given rise to
interpretation, misunderstanding,
poetry, art, conversation.
We have a common skill: language.
We all talk.
Each of our words has
more than one meaning.
We are all beings that are
different from the bees.
The bees, they also communicate
but their [inaudible] has signals
that mean only one thing, hardly a
bee will write a poet or sing a song
and bees are much less
complicated than we are.
There is no work or reward or
queen destitution in beehives.
There are no problems, couple
problems between the bees,
among the bees [inaudible]
discussion with teenage larvae.
No bee thinks with nostalgia on
his parents or in a lost love
and not one of them has
yet been found weeping
when the moon reflects
itself in the sea.
On the other side, words
are like parasites.
Words are a cancer that
afflicts the human being.
Words are also the only
medicine for many disease.
Mother tongue is the
beginning of our language.
Mother tongue is our singular
tongue, unique for everyone.
You cannot study this tongue.
It appears in the mother
with her child.
The mother tongue is a strong
link between mother and child
without words but with letters
and sounds, a-ha, a-ho, uum.
The Tower of Babel is right.
There was a lost language.
It's our mother tongue.
It was a time of full
understanding between human beings.
This is gone and never
will come back.
After this language.
So this means he's
right, the ho, the ha,
the uum, are they from the child?
Do they come from the mother?
They are sounds and
the mother repeating
and molding the child's sounds
consolidates that [inaudible]
that someday will be
poetry, [inaudible], song.
They make essentially phonetic
properties of the word,
the polyphony of the
word, a song for example,
experience of the mother tongue
happens for all human beings.
Punctuation seems to be another
step after this experience.
Commemorating a day of his childhood
in which his father read kids
"The Nightingale," Borges
says he understood nothing
but writes in poetic art.
He says, I had considered
language as a way of saying things,
complaining or to say
that one was happy or sad.
I knew that language could
also be a music and a passion
and so poetry was revealed to me.
Borges in "The Library of Babel,"
the character that Borges wrote
about him, looks for an
impossible book, a book capable
of saying everything,
of quoting everything.
In the story, the whole book
is searching for a catalog
that contains all the catalogues
and that would contain itself,
that book that would contain itself
if it were the [inaudible] book
is what made Bertrand Russell the
mathematician, and he thought
that is an impossible point
and what [inaudible]
will demonstrate
with the number [inaudible] the
impossibility of its existence.
There are no identical books in the
vast library of books, says Borges.
I have seen from the page
of Russell, he said that,
the doctrine of sets which has
as figures the letters
of the Hebrew alphabet.
In that delicate labyrinth,
I was not able to penetrate.
That is why if we know how to
read the plot that is our life,
we can read something as a book.
Babel is nothing but an infinite
game of chance, said Borges.
If babel is the universe,
a lottery, a library,
let's play with our own
letters to tell another story,
not to blame ourselves because
of the misunderstanding.
The language like in harmony
is a myth and because of that,
we have many languages and it's
not a punishment but is a gift.
I will finish with
a quote from Lacan.
This is a quote.
"We believe that we say what we want
but this is what others have wanted,
more specifically our
family that speaks to us.
We are spoken and because of this,
we make of any chance expression
something that directs us.
There is indeed a plot.
We call it our destiny.
Many Jews, not all the Jews,
but many Jews believe
they found the total book.
Borges is not so sure.
And psychoanalysis is convinced that
each person could read his own text,
could touch and change a
letter or two without thinking
that it's a sacred text and
then this universe could be a
different one.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Saul Sosnowski:
Tova just asked me
if she was understood,
if it was clear.
Absolutely clear.
Whether we agree, that's
another story
but this is the chance
we have right now.
It was interesting to hear
that noise from the background.
And those must be the
workers building the tower
or taking it down.
Who knows.
But anyway, we do have a few
minutes for questions, for comments,
for trying to explore some
of the points both Mirta
and Tova have raised
and we'll see --
There are several hands coming up.
I was given instructions
to repeat the questions.
So please make them very brief.
My memory is not as strong
as the ones we just heard.
Okay, let's start from there.
>> I have a question for Mirta.
When you were starting to create the
[inaudible] exhibition in October,
how did you plan that out?
Did you storyboard your idea
and figure out how it's going
to look, the exhibition itself?
>> Saul Sosnowski: Okay, the
question -- No, no, no, [inaudible].
The question is how did
Mirta conceive of the work
that she's going to be presenting
at the Biennale in Jerusalem,
whether there was a storyboard, in
general how did she plan that work.
>> Mirta Kupferminc: Actually
just perhaps the three
of us can stand now.
Okay. We will walk.
Thank you for your question.
Well, you know it's interesting
but I would answer if I'm sincere
that I never begin and
I never finish a work.
Works are -- A project
is not suddenly born
by inspiration or so, no.
Everything comes from not only
the previous work but my own life.
So these are my thoughts.
Sometimes I feel that I'm
always making the same
with different shapes.
Look, only with the Tower
of Babel if I must choose,
I have many more, but I must choose.
So everything is the same
and everything is myself.
So [inaudible] I would say that I
choose a title based on what I want
to mean and I join my little
parts trying to express that.
>> Saul Sosnowski:
Okay, don't go away.
You were right.
Stand. Next question.
Please.
>> This is for Mirta.
[inaudible] the most important
language is the mother's language,
mother's tongue, and Mirta,
you mentioned that you
were [inaudible] Polish.
>> Saul Sosnowski: And Hungarian.
>> [inaudible].
Could you tell us a
little bit [inaudible].
>> Saul Sosnowski: Hungarians
don't know [inaudible].
>> Mirta Kupferminc: No, Hungarians
don't know but Polish, yes.
>> Saul Sosnowski: Polish, yes.
Okay, but I will let
her handle that one.
>> Mirta Kupferminc: Thank you.
Look, I think that my mother
tongue is this, is what I am,
everything, because it's true.
I heard many, many languages and
many kinds of mother tongues.
If I understand well what
Tova tries to express is
that this mother language is
something that is not a --
It's a unique language between
that mother and that child,
that of course I had with no
other language of countries.
But I think that here
in what I share with all
of you is my real mother tongue,
is my being, my being Argentinean,
Jewish, Hungarian, Polish
woman, brown eyes and I think
that being a mother, a wife, a
friend and now speaking with you,
you are also now all
part of what I am.
So I think that what I
make is my mother tongue.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
>> I want to ask a question
because I am an artist too.
I'm intrigued with your concept
of making the journey of words
from the mouth into
visualization and I wonder
when you cut the rubber,
how do you get the rubber,
how do you cut it out?
What size is the piece and so forth
because you have this wonderful flow
and I tried to figure
out how you did it.
>> Mirta Kupferminc: Your name?
>> My name is Phyllis [inaudible].
>> Mirta Kupferminc: Phyllis.
Thank you, Phyllis.
Phyllis is asking me how
do I cut these big rubbers
into such a huge size and how's
the proceeding that I use.
Very well, I buy the flat material.
I draw -- I am a very expert at this
time to write a, yes, in reverse,
backward in mirror, yes,
like in the mirror way.
So I write everything from the back
because I don't want it to be seen
in the front, all the lines,
so I write everything.
It's a drawing, somehow and
afterwards with a regular cutter,
a knife, a very little one, I cut.
Very patient.
I have an assistant in my studio
and we are working for years already
for three years to make this
what I will present now.
So it's everything hand cut and
afterwards I join the flat plates.
Let's say they are soft but
they are plates and that's how.
>> Thank you.
>> Mirta Kupferminc: Thanks to you.
>> Tova Shvartzman:
[Inaudible] is a word that came
from Hebrew, [inaudible].
It's not language.
It's tongue.
Tongue and language
are different things.
[foreign word] is mother tongue.
Mother language is another thing.
My mother, when she used to
speak with me is mother language,
Spanish for example, but
mother tongue is what I have
in my body, without words.
So what Mirta says is true, the
mother tongue we cannot spell it.
You cannot translate it.
You are that.
After that, you speak.
We speak.
>> I've got a question
for both of you.
The question is do you think that we
should be, I don't know how to say,
scared that we are losing a
lot of [inaudible] languages
of our [inaudible], Spanish,
Deutsch, whatever language is
in this globalization, when today
for example I don't know maybe
because [inaudible] they have
a common language [inaudible]
because it doesn't matter if
you speak, if you Deutsch,
if you speak espanol or
you speak English, right,
they are all texting
when they communicate.
Do you understand what I'm saying?
They are words but they
are coming into a language
of an entire generation
that became like universal
and as the words are becoming
universal, so is the country.
Right? So now the [inaudible]
are replacing [inaudible] now
everybody's [inaudible].
So it's happening in the
language as it happened
in the culture [inaudible].
Do you fear that we are losing that?
>> Saul Sosnowski: In other
words, the question is,
if I understand you correctly
and if not you will readjust,
the question is whether
globalization is in fact a threat
to all the languages that
both of them were mentioning
as mother tongue, mother language
and asking that regardless
of where children are or
teenagers are, they're all texting.
I will add before letting
them answer, they're texting
in a different language still.
It's a means.
It is not the conveyer in itself.
But let them answer
the question, please.
>> Tova Shvartzman: So
what I am scared of is
that the mother will be a robot,
not that the mother will
speak the same language,
English, for the people.
If the mother is a robot, the
mother tongue doesn't exist.
You understand me?
>> Mirta Kupferminc: I have
my own opinion about this.
I see as an observer what is
happening and I have a lot less age
but you less age than
you, perhaps two years,
but I think that we cannot
change what already exist,
that the world is changing.
So I think we are all the
time inventing, let's say,
new ways of communication.
And if I like it or not,
nobody cares so much.
I think that everything
already changed
and we will continue changing
and of course we lose.
But in my opinion,
this is completely personal,
we cannot do nothing.
Yes, personally, we can do
with our life and our work,
treasure what we want but
we will find people who care
and we will find people
who does not.
This is my opinion.
>> Saul Sosnowski: Well, one of the
dangers is we are losing a language
and I talk in this
language every day.
That is not coming back.
So the fear is very,
very legitimate.
Yes, please.
>> George Steiner in his
wonderful book "After Babel" talks
about translation and he
says that in this process
of translation we sometimes
get a glimmer
of the ancient original
universal language.
I wonder if you might
respond to that.
>> Saul Sosnowski: The question is
more than a question it's a comment
about George Steiner's
"After Babel" that he says
that in a translation
we get a glimmer
of what an ancient language may have
been in the process of translating.
And the question is whether
either or both of them would
like to comment on George
Steiner's statement.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
You are seeing it right
now happening.
>> Tova Shvartzman: Okay.
Okay. I think translation is
always betrayal but it's good.
It's very good because
it's interpretation.
I think he's right, he's right.
But he's [inaudible] in the West.
He's in the West.
He's not an Oriental thought.
Oriental thoughts, I think, I
don't know, but what we can read
and understand from
Oriental thought the letters,
the ideograms are something
very different from our logic.
So I don't know if George
Steiner [inaudible] will be right
because Western thought is to
interpret always, always, always.
Chinese thought in the ideogram is
to [inaudible] the picture
and the letter together.
We separate that.
There's Mirta and I.
You understand what I say?
>> Yeah but when you
translate [inaudible].
>> Tova Shvartzman: Haiku is
very, very hard to translate.
Haiku, you cannot, you cannot.
We are talking -- Yes,
interpreting, yes but not translate.
It's a very big betrayal
to the Haiku.
Because of that, we cannot
speak so easy with East,
Oriental, Eastern people.
We cannot because that's another
universe, another mother tongue.
>> Mirta Kupferminc: I
have something to add.
I have something to
add to Tova's comment.
I love poetry and if my English,
with the English I have, I am able,
I can read a book and
enjoy the book.
If I read poetry -- A
book in English, sorry.
If I read poetry in English,
although I understand the
words, I don't feel the poem.
I don't enjoy it.
I understand the words.
I understand but I don't feel.
It's not my language.
With Haiku, of course,
it's impossible.
But I think that this happens
sometimes although you know very,
very well another language
but I think it's very hard
to feel a second language.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Saul Sosnowski: Another question?
[ Inaudible Question ]
The question is whether Tova
has her paper in Spanish.
The answer is not yet
but stay tuned.
Sorry, but I saw the writing on the
wall and it's coming, it's coming.
Gail. Why don't you, since
you are the [inaudible]?
>> Gail Shirazi: That's okay.
What is the connection
between Borges and Judaism?
He's involved in the Kabbalah.
He wrote on babel.
What is -- What's his interest?
>> Tova Shvartzman:
The expert is here.
>> Saul Sosnowski:
Yeah, she's right there.
The question that Gail asked
is what is the connection
between Borges and Judaism.
Tova, it's all yours.
Go ahead.
>> Tova Shvartzman: He's the expert.
>> Saul Sosnowski: This was a trap.
Anyway, I'm just supposed
to moderate.
>> Mirta Kupferminc: We
will moderate you now.
>> Saul Sosnowski: Good luck.
Good luck.
Very, very briefly.
Borges did write quite
a bit of text.
He wrote both short stories and
poems that link the many traditions
that he's interested
in to various cultures,
to various other traditions.
One of those is Judaism.
I go in very, very long way
not to say the most obvious,
namely let's not trap
Borges into just one box.
Borges was interested in Judaism.
He was interested in Kabbalah but
he was interested in Buddhism.
He was interested in all
kinds of other things.
He has a very famous text that is
called "The Vindication of Kabbalah"
but that is one of several
texts that have the word
"vindication" in the title.
Basically what he tried to do is
to understand why did the
Kabbalists engage in that kind
of esoteric knowledge, is
that kind of esoteric study.
Basically what he tries to
do is say, not he tries,
he did say very intelligently
the following.
If in fact you believe that the
Torah, the first five books of the
"Bible" are the utterance of a
God and the God is all knowing,
all powerful, et cetera, et
cetera, you cannot assume
that that is just casual
text, namely every text,
every letter has a
meaning and, therefore,
it is your job to interpret.
Again, I would go into that
statement that Tova made before,
namely you're engaging
in interpretation
and the Kabbalists are doing that
for whatever purpose they had
but that is what they were doing.
So what Borges is doing by
saying a vindication of Kabbalah,
he's justifying the
Kabbalists' approach to language.
Now that is an opening, but I'm
the moderator, so that's enough.
The two of them will talk.
>> Tova Shvartzman:
And another answer
to that we have always a discussion,
the three of us, about Borges,
the Kabbalah, the "Bible"
if they are art or not.
They're sacred text to some people
but perhaps they are
literature also like Borges.
So we have the beauty of two of
them, the Kabbalah and Borges.
The beauty, they are expressions
there that you cannot only someone
that is inspired can wrote like
Borges or like the Kabbalists one.
Perhaps they are literature,
not only sacred text,
or not a sacred text.
>> Mirta Kupferminc: Sorry.
Dealing with so many
women is the problem.
If I -- As an artist, I am always
giving my own point of view.
I would say it depends to whom.
It's not the problem what it is.
It is different things
for different people.
For some it may be something
sacred and written by God.
And for others, literature.
And that's why the biggest
world, the world is very big
and we can understand what we want
and interpret what we want
of the same situation.
Very political.
>> Saul Sosnowski: Correct.
So politically correct in a
town like this, it's unheard of.
Please.
>> I think the more you
think about language,
the more complicated it gets
because there's body language
and artistic visual language
and there kinesthetic language
and we're always [inaudible]
interpreting
and Borges said [inaudible]
the original should be at least
as good as the translation.
I love that because it puts
[inaudible] how do we understand
people, you know, where
did words come
in because I [inaudible] I
mean you, I don't know so well.
>> Saul Sosnowski:
It's not worth it.
>> So that's my question.
In other words, language is so
complicated and the more you know
about it, the less you know.
How does that affect [inaudible]?
And the other thing I just want
to say, these are more complicated
than [inaudible] when
it comes to language.
It's just a different [inaudible].
>> Tova Shvartzman: They are
complicated but they are --
>> Saul Sosnowski: If
you remember way back
when we started this session,
I asked you to make the
questions very short
because I have to repeat
the questions.
So --
>> Language is complicated.
How do you deal with it?
>> Saul Sosnowski: Love it!
Language is complicated.
How do you deal with it?
Now that makes a lot of sense.
Now please, you're both on.
>> Mirta Kupferminc:
To whom the question?
>> Saul Sosnowski: To both of you.
>> Mirta Kupferminc: To both.
>> Saul Sosnowski: Have fun.
>> Mirta Kupferminc: Okay.
With my works, I will
begin from an anecdote.
Many years ago I had to lecture,
actually you invited me to Milwaukee
to teach with a [inaudible]
students and I went with my son.
My son was 15 years old then at
that time and he asked me, "Mom,
you have to speak in English.
Aren't you afraid you will not be
able to express what you want?"
And I answered, "Look, I am
not teaching English grammar.
I am speaking about what
I am and I know who I am.
And if I need a word, I will ask
someone please to help me to say it.
No, no, I am not afraid."
And answering, I think
that we say what we want
to say or we want to express.
We cannot control what the other
person will understand or read
or perceive of the work or reading
the book or we cannot control that.
So personally, I'm not
worried about that.
>> Saul Sosnowski: And that
is how [inaudible] was born.
>> Mirta Kupferminc: Exactly.
>> Saul Sosnowski: Tova.
>> Tova Shvartzman: Perhaps,
I don't know if I could answer
your question, but you know Babel,
many people said that is in
Hebrew [inaudible] Babel --
>> Saul Sosnowski: To mix up.
>> Tova Shvartzman: Mix up.
But the word "babel" is
babel el is door to God.
It's not [inaudible] mix up.
It's babel el.
Like babel what, like babel el,
there are two words in
Babylonian language.
So the meaning and the [inaudible]
of babel run through at times
and now we said babel is to mix up.
But if you go to the
root, it's not like that.
Which I choose.
Yeah. So if language
is so complicated,
we must I think we must do the, a
the [inaudible] to understand us,
there is a misunderstanding
all the time and it's good.
It's good.
If not, we are, we will
not talk each other.
We will be silent.
Thank you.
>> Saul Sosnowski: To say something
like this in Washington, DC,
about misunderstandings and to be
quiet and not text and not tweet
and things like that, that's
a very welcome gate to God.
Thank you all so very, very
much for joining us [applause].
Thank you, Gail.
Thank you to embassy.
>> Mirta Kupferminc: Thank
you, Gail for everything.
Thank you, Gail.
>> Gail Shirazi: I want to thank
our presenters and I just want
to comment on Mirta's work.
The more we look at it, when I did
the flier I kept looking at it.
Every time I looked at that
picture, I saw something else.
I think Mirta's work, you
have to really keep looking
at it and looking into it.
And I'm sure there's so
much more I'm missing.
And thank you for having
so much of you in the work
and so much in your work.
Thank you all for coming
[applause] and I want to thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.